I believe in one or two solutions I
think either one we need to normalize
getting married without the state's
involvement that would be my first
answer or two if we need the state's
involvement we need to set up license
renewals the same way a driver's license
need to be renewed a gun license needs
to be renewed that's interesting you
know I think marriage license should be
renewed and if you choose not to renew
it you shouldn't need to involve the
courts and both parties should walk away
scot-free
oh that's an interesting idea I've never
thought of that
like a license renewal what do you think
should women with the way the laws are
now should they require marriage before
they carry
so yes and no yes that's good advice for
women but no for men
to more liability if I'm being honest
okay so if you had a daughter and she
said
I'm with a guy he wants to have kids in
a family but he doesn't want to get
married legally would you tell her to
stay or go
I would tell her to go okay